oh my god looking great sign to the
coffee place
oh my god I know thank you so much I
found it on Yelp and I was like this is
it this is the one so cozy and quaint
yeah it's so cozy like can't you feel
like a big heavy blankets around your
shoulders and you're in front of a
fireplace with a really handsome man was
actually a lumberjack and he loves you
for your mind and your body I really
love that to happen to me Sunday I'm so
glad that this coffee shop has cushioned
seats because like I've lost so much
weight this year and like my butt is so
bony Logan actually gained some weight
so anyway I wrote a prayer about coffee
oh my god can you please tell it like I
you know we're in public and not church
but like just like yeah how coffee is my
best friend till the end just let me be
all I need is coffee
so anyway anyway anyway
Mary Mary Thompson Mary oh my gosh Mary
Thompson first of all first of all she's
like so sweet she's so sweet first of
all she's so kind mary has a heart of
course of all like her hair is so
beautifu stuball like your eyes are so
blue most of all her thighs are so blue
oh my god I've been looking into an
ocean to flounder oh my god hey what's
that butter by Mary is such a [ __ ]
because she was like oh my god
Chanel I like your shoes I'm like what
do you mean by like do you like them
like you want to steal them you want to
wear them or do you mean my like like I
would hate them and I want to like burn
them
I mean it's like kind of like rude of
her to do that because like obviously
everybody hates your shoes and like
nobody likes senseless Bruford do you me
like I like your shoes cuz everybody
knows that your shoes are disgusts me
okay so like I can't stand Mary because
she comes up to me and she's like oh my
god I love the way that you do reports
like I love the way that you'd like to
use purple ink sometimes and I'm like
hold on first of all are you calling a
professional because I think I'm such a
fifty thing to say and I was like how
dare you marry I'm going to talk to you
look at your face anymore well she has
to look at you this year sometimes look
like a clown
so anyway this copies so good it is
hanging out of my belly uh alright you
go ahead use the restroom go ahead beep
I gotta like I really want you to cause
like I've already is it it really nice
ham soaps and lotions like I know that
you need it for your whatever you have
in your hands like I do it oh my god
you